you might recall yesterday we had a look
at a diagram like this you do not need
to redraw this because you should
already have this in your book I want
you to have a look carefully at what
this looks like and see if you remember
don't look at your book see if you
remember what's is talking about there
are two angles in here that are
important where are they
there's one at the center and then
there's one at the circumference you can
see I've highlighted in orange over here
see this arc voice of the angles that
you just described are standing on that
arc okay so what's the relationship do
you know the relationship angle at the
center is twice or double the angle of
the circumference standing on the same
arc okay so if I call this theta then
this would be two theta
okay the question was very insightful
you raised
yeah but the proof that I did for this
depended on being able to do this
construction right remember I sliced it
down the middle I made those two
isosceles triangles but and this is what
you can do on your first diagram over
here there is a way to construct the
same situation but different enough that
this method of proof doesn't work let me
show you go ahead and draw this one this
one very important proving a squirrel
squirrel all over this area this is your
question here before you are your angle
on this at the center here but if I
don't draw the angle on the
circumference at a nice neat spot like
up here if I draw it at an awkward spot
like say over here the diagram you get
looks quite different this is what it
looks like it's not that this is the
same situation angle at the centre and
the circumference standing on the same
arc and in fact the other property still
holds which is one of all the things
about it however I can't like where
where would that line go see my line
that goes through the center is not
going to survive that thing up into like
it did before nice and neatly so how is
this going to work
interestingly
it is still going to work remarkably
simply so remember this time last time
rather I drew a line from the point of
the circumference to the center I drew
that radius I went a little bit further
so I could do that exterior angle
betraying will think I'm going to do the
same thing over here so here's the angle
adversity conference and I'm going to
join it up to the center like so excuse
me so how am I going to get to like
what's my aim I want to show you that
this angle in here is double this angle
over here okay
and I want to use some basic geometry
and isosceles triangles because we know
there are everywhere to prove that let's
begin by just giving some names to these
things okay so do you remember what I
called I called each of these little
angles that make up the angles doing I
call them in exile like I think I called
an alpha beta remember that so I'm going
to call this guy alpha and this guy be
none okay the difference here is that
the angle I'm going to end up with this
one is here it's not going to be 2 alpha
plus 2 beta is it in this case on this
diagram what do I want that angle to be
just 2 beta just double that angle on
the circumference the alpha is not
included but it's kind of hanging out
there on the slide okay there's loads of
isosceles triangles in here I can see at
least two that relate immediately to the
two angles that I've just drawn anyone
want to suggest to me let's put some
names on the showi
let's call this oh let's call this a B
we'll make this guy C we'd anyone like
to describe and isosceles track our name
this let's call that P whatever I'd like
to describe an isosceles triangle for me
and tell me what to put in there
oh-oh-oh be these guys a radio let's
mark that in so therefore what statement
can I make about angles that goes with
that pair of equal signs any takers
everything is named you don't a point
you don't have to use vague words you
can tell me which angle you need yeah Oh
B P is equal to Oh a P thumbs up right
those are both V on there the base
angles of this isosceles triangle right
so that makes that alpha okay so far so
good is another isosceles triangle in
there can you tell me where it is oh and
oh see also radii so in fact I can
market that as equal so what would be
the pair of equal angles that matches
that pair of equal size okay so you've
got alpha plus beta in this corner which
means you get alpha plus beta in this
corner so far so good
are you happy with that me too
okay yeah pause rumor here is the
interesting part we've done the easy
bits remember where I want to get to I
want to get to here let me give you a
couple of minutes to have a think about
how you get there stitch you've got an
idea call me over done what I would like
to do is make sure your pens are down
your eyes are up because if you blink
you will miss it it's that quick okay I
want you to look at that or what's there
and also once you remember how we did it
last time
do you remember for instance if I call
this alpha then you've got another alpha
in the corner just like we have right
and then directly from there what
knowledge did I use to go straight to
this angle what did I do
I used the exterior angle of a triangle
do you remember that and I just said
immediately that's two alpha okay you
can do an intermediate step you can work
out what this is with the angles on the
triangle if you wanted to and then you
can work out this angle codes angles on
a straight line okay but you don't need
to you can go there directly and there's
something similar happening here
remember where I'm going remember where
I'm going this is um this angle here is
my destination okay
so what is the quickest possible path to
get there tell me what that angle is
equal to one step only one step you can
go there directly yeah alpha plus 2 beta
do you see why it's alpha plus 2 beta
because it's the exterior angle of which
triangle what's the name of the triangle
ACP very good ok so do you see it yet
did you catch it
what'd I just say alpha plus 2 beat up
but as opposed to beta is not just the
exterior angle of this triangle it is
also the exterior angle of OBP isn't it
this guy over here so it says the reason
that it's still the sum of the opposite
two interior angles but you know this
one
it's alpha so therefore this has to be 2
beta checkmate in two moves ok